et on a réussi à sortir les dizaines de
milliers des centaines de milliers
d'aînés de la pauvreté au filet
dernières années on a on a diminué
depuis 2015 le taux de pauvreté chez les
aînés de 20% est-ce que la pauvreté a
autant baissé chez les personnes âgées
de 65 ans et plus
[Musique]
oui c'est vrai mais il ya des nuances à
apporter
quand justin trudeau est arrivé au
pouvoir en 2015 le taux de pauvreté des
années était de 7 % au pays s'il était
resté à ce niveau là plus de 460 mille
personnes âgées se serait retrouvé en
situation de faible revenu en 2019 mais
le taux a baissé à 5,4 pour cent il y en
a donc 112 mille de moins ça représente
une baisse qui dépasse un peu les 20%
évoqué par justin trudeau mais on ne
peut pas dire que des centaines de
milliers d'années sont sortis de la
pauvreté
vous vous demandez sûrement comment on
calcule le seuil de faible revenu
selon statistique canada c'est quand une
personne consacre une part de ses
revenus 20% supérieurs à la moyenne des
gens pour ses besoins de base comme se
nourrir et se loger
maintenant pourquoi la pauvreté at elle
baissé chez les aînés la bonification du
supplément de revenu garanti a
possiblement joué un rôle cette
prestation là qui est versé aux aînés
les plus pauvres a augmenté davantage
que le coût de la vie
mais il faut aussi ajouter que des gens
prennent leur retraite en masse depuis
quelques années et qu'ils sont mieux
nantis qu'auparavant ils contribuent
donc à faire baisser le taux de pauvreté
parmi les pays du g7 le canada arrive
troisième derrière la france et
l'allemagne pour ce qui est du taux de
pauvreté le plus faible chez les aînés
mais c'est au canada que l'intensité de
la pauvreté et la moins forte ça veut
dire qu'il ya moins de personnes âgées
dans des situations d'extrême pauvreté
comparativement aux autres pays